foreign
[Music]
it up
for me
[Music]
to find a place
foreign
[Music]
drinking champagne
foreign
s what up I hope you enjoyed this video
I thought that light display was pretty
cool and it made for a good excuse to do
a little bit of flow
um real quick I just want to put out a
huge thank you to ultra POI for
sponsoring this video and making it
possible for me to get out and do cool
flow videos like this with interesting
pieces of public art if you'd like to
grab a set of those orb POI LED contact
POI that I was using in this video you
can do that by using the promo code
drexfactor with a zero instead of an O
at checkout that will get you a discount
on your order and it helps out the
channel so everybody wins hey Ultra POI
thank you so much for your continued
support of my channel
speaking of thank yous big thanks to the
Friends of the channel uh thanks to dark
monk fire Mecca flowfests flow toys
juggling calling pyroterra light toys
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I've got down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel That
is Lane machinski and Becca becklinen
thank you both so very much for your
support from my work and my mission and
finally this video would not be possible
were it not for the awesome support of
all of these nice people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they just like the people
listed down in the description helps
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all for your very generous support
and if you're out there watching enjoy
these videos and would like to support
them you can do so by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get a whole access to a whole host
of awesome rewards including early
access to my content so go check that
out please and thank you finally if
you're interested in checking out more
of my flow videos I will include a link
to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you're watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here based upon your
past viewing habits so maybe give that a
look as well thanks so much have a good
one and I will see you with a new video
real soon peace